ich habe mich Theorien Sichtweisen und
teilweise auch Gruppierungen geöffnet
und den ich mich ohne Wenn und Aber
distanziere und los sage insbesondere
und vor allem auch von Rechten und
verschwörerischen Gruppen vor kurzem
erscheint nach langer Funkstille dieses
Video von Xavier Naidoo doch von wem und
was distanzierte sich da eigentlich
genau die Schockwellen auf telegram
waren groß jahrelang war Naidoo einer
der größten verschwörungsinfluencer auf
der Plattform doch wer steckt jetzt
eigentlich wirklich hinter seinem
telegram Kanal ich glaube früher oder
später wird es ohne das jetzt heraus
zu irgendeiner Form von Gewalt kommen
was auf dem telegram Account von Xavier
Naidoo abgeht ist gar nicht mal so
witzig sondern im Wahrheit echt
gefährlich er leugnete die corona-krise
erleugnete den Klimawandel er hetzte
gegen geflüchtete Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund und gegen Juden
und Jüdinnen und das obwohl man von
Xavier Naidoo selbst schon seit einiger
Zeit nichts mehr auf dem Kanal hört die
Gruppe läuft aber weiter stattdessen
Posten also Rechte Köpfe die noch
gefährlicher sind es gibt quasi eine Art
Fake von Xavier Naidoo auf telegram in
diesem Video zeigen wir euch welche
rechten Drahtzieher in tatsächlich
hinter dem telegram Kanal von Xavier
Naidoo stecken und in welche krassen
Ecken von telegram dieser Kanal führt
das ist die allererste Nachricht in
einer telegram-gruppe die sich Xavier
Naidoo zuordnen lässt sie ist vom 5
Februar 2020 aus der Gruppe
deutsch-russische Seelen und der
Betreiber beschreibt die Gruppe wie
folgt
nicht damit einverstanden was der Westen
mit Russland macht wir die
deutsch-russischen Seelen sind nicht
bereit dem Treiben tatenlos zuzuschauen
wir sind nicht jene welche im Internet
mit dem Finger auf Missstände zeigen wir
sind die welche die Tat umsetzen na du
bleib erstmal stiller Mitleser in der
Gruppe kurze Zeit später beginnt dann
seine Karriere als telegram influencer
ich habe fast tolle Menschen lieb aber
was wenn fast jeden Tag ein Mord
geschieht bei dem der Gast im Gastgeber
einen Lebensstil dann muss sich harte
Worte wählen denn keiner darf in meine
Leute quälen ab Anfang März 2020 taucht
er in Gruppen auf in denen sich Fans von
ihm schon versammelt hatten kurze Zeit
später steigt er dann auch richtig einen
scame und fängt an Post zu verfassen
auch in seinem eigenen Kanal den er
allerdings nicht selbst gegründet hat
sondern in denen er von einer Userin
namens Engel mit Feuer eingeladen wurde
diese Person wird auch noch eine größere
Rolle spielen aber dazu später mehr
böse vollenburger ist datenanalyst bei
cemas beim Center für Monitoring Analyse
und Strategie er hat für uns Xavier
naidooze Aktivitäten auf telegram
ausgewertet auf telegram was man
generell zusammenfassen kann als
antisemitische verschwörungsmythen das
kann dann verschwörungserzählungen über
die corona-pandemie sein das können
verschwörungserzählungen über die
Ukraine sein allen gemeinsam ist dass er
eigentlich einen Feind dahinter vermutet
nämlich Jüdinnen und Juden was nein du
da postet das geht sogar so weit dass es
strafrechtlich relevant wird am 22
Februar 2021 teilt er die Protokolle der
Weisen von Zion eine antisemitische
Herzschrift die Fassung der teilt kommt
von Alfred Rosenberg dem früheren
Chefideologen der NSDAP es ist quasi das
Basiswerk für antisemitische Ideologie
und wird auch heute noch als
Rechtfertigung für antisemitische
Gewalttaten und vernichtungsfantasien
genutzt der Kanal von Xavier Naidoo
funktioniert wie eine
radikalisierungsmaschine fast schon wie
eine Einstiegsdroge kann
ist das was man als Gatekeeper
bezeichnen würde auf telegram er
erreicht theoretisch 110.000 Abonnenten
und es gibt sehr viele kleine Accounts
die vielleicht nur 1000 oder 100
Abonnenten erreichen können das heißt
die sind oft auch angewiesen das andere
Menschen auf ihren Kanal finden wenn
Xavier na du so einen kleinen Kanal
promoted dann führt das auch dazu dass
es die Reichweite von diesem kleinen
Kanal erhöht und eben möglicherweise
sogar in diese kleineren extremeren
Bereiche dank Xavier wenn du Menschen
noch hineingezogen wurden und sich
vielleicht radikalisiert haben wenn man
auf diese Kanäle klickt dann sieht man
tatsächlich auch so Glorifizierung der
NSDAP und Adolf Hitlers
er teilt die eher unproblematischen
Inhalte dieser Kanäle muss man dazu
sagen aber er macht damit ein Tor auf in
diese Gruppen reinzukommen und in diese
Kanäle reinzukommen über 150 Mal haben
hollenburger und sein Team
weitergeleitete Nachrichten aus Kanälen
gezählt die dem sogenannten terrorgram
zugeordnet werden können solchen Kanälen
treibt Xavier Naidoo seine zu erinnern
in die Arme für die Drahtzieher in der Q
Enden Szene Querdenker für Rechtsextreme
hat Xavier Naidoo einen extrem wichtige
Funktion er hat natürlich auch Fans die
nicht verschwörungsideologinnen sind die
nicht an Verschwörung Erzählungen
glauben und deswegen war es eine sehr
dankbare Persönlichkeit die zum Beispiel
rechtsextreme auch genutzt haben um
ihren Einfluss zu erweitern man hat
plötzlich andere Menschen erreicht als
man das vorher getan hat und Xavier
Naidoo ist nicht der einzige Promi der
zum verschwörungsinfluencer geworden ist
auch andere Prominente betreiben
telegram-kanäle den tausende Menschen
folgen der ehemaligen
Tagesschausprecherin Eva Hermann zum
Beispiel folgen mittlerweile mehr als
200.000 Menschen sie teilt auf ihrem
Kanal Artikel Fotos und Videos wie am
Fließband die Themen reichen von
corona-politik bis hin zu spirituellen
Ratschlägen aber besonders gerne macht
sie Werbung für Produkte die ihre
abonnent:innen dann im Kopf Verlag
bestellen können das ist einen Verlag
der besonders für Publikationen im
verschwörungsideologischen Bereich
bekannt ist ein was da im telegram
Universum Michael Wendler mit immerhin
mehr als 130.000 AbonnentInnen der
Schlagersänger teilt auf telegram Fake
News bezeichnet Deutschland als KZ und
spricht von langzeittoten durch die
corona-impfung und diese drei
verschwörungsinfluencer:innen reposten
sich auch fleißig gegenseitig telegram
wirkt wie ein rechtsfreier Raum in dem
Verschwörungsideologien ungehindert
wachsen und gedeihen können aber warum
wird gerade auf dieser Plattform so viel
problematischer Content geteilt um das
zu verstehen müssen wir uns die
Ursprünge von telegram anschauen
telegram wurde in Russland von Pavel
durov gegründet Pavel durov wurde mal
als russischer Mark Zuckerberg
bezeichnet der hatte nämlich dort VK
gegründet das ist sowas wie das
russische Facebook im Jahr 2014 ist
durov mit dem Kreml in Konflikt geraten
weil er sich weigerte den Account von
Putin Gegnern Nawalny zu sperren infolge
dieser staatlichen Repressionen des
duroff ins Exil geflohen er hat VK
verkauft und eine Plattform aufgebaut
die komplett unabhängig von staatlichen
Kontrollen sein sollte das war die
Geburtsstunde von telegram leider
entzieht sich telegram nicht nur
Autokraten sondern auch der Regulierung
durch unseren Rechtsstaat das was der
Kanal auf telegram vorbereitet könnte er
wahrscheinlich nicht auf den anderen
Plattformen wie Youtube und Facebook
verbreiten weil es mittlerweile deutlich
stärkere Moderierung dort gibt und weil
das was da auf dem Kanal geteilt wird in
ganz vielen Plattformen aus hassreder
bezeichnet würden würde oder sogar unter
volksverletzungen fällt deswegen
konzentriert sich auch gerade so viel
auf telegram dort wird sehr wenig
gelöscht mittlerweile mehr als früher
aber es geht einfach deutlich mehr an
Hass als bei allen anderen Plattformen
der Stadt versucht zu handeln und
telegram zu regulieren leider bisher
nicht besonders erfolgreich was lange
gefehlt hat sind ansprechpartner:innen
bei der Plattform es gibt das
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz in
Deutschland dass jede soziale Plattform
dazu zwingt dass sie zum Beispiel
eindeutig strafbare Inhalte in kurzer
Zeit löschen müssen aber dass sie auch
einen Ansprechpartner oder der anspre
Partnerin der Regierung zur Verfügung
stellen oder den Behörden zur Verfügung
stellen das Gesetz ist gültig das Gesetz
ist da aber wenn man keinen
Ansprechpartner hat oder keine Adresse
wo man die Strafe hinschicken könnte die
auch in den Millionen gehen kann bei den
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz was macht
man dann damit und ich glaube das war
die Krux der letzten Jahre der
Bundesregierung in Deutschland dass man
genau dieses Problem hatte an wen
schickt man denn diese Nachrichten diese
Vorladung für Gerichte seit Juli 2021
wurde es plötzlich still und es gibt
keine direkten persönlichen Nachrichten
mehr von Xavier Naidoo auf seinem
telegram-kanal und trotzdem wird fleißig
weiter gepostet denn weil du hat seinen
Kanal nicht selbst gegründet hinter
seinen Kanälen stecken vor allem zwei
Personen die auf telegram sehr aktiv
sind und die halten das Ganze am Laufen
das sind in persona Engel mit Feuer und
Frank der Reisende beide
Schreiben auf seinen Kanälen beide geben
sich auch so aus als wäre wären sie
Xavier Natur und vielen Punkten
zumindest war das bei Engel mit Feuer so
bis dass finanzierungsvideo von Xavier
Naidoo erschienen aber dazu später mehr
erstmal der Reihe nach Frank der
Reisende bürgerlich Frank schreibmüller
kommt gebürtig aus Leipzig ist 39 Jahre
alt und auf telegram sehr bekannt und
extrem gut vernetzt Frank schreibmüller
läuft bei Neonazi auf Märchen mit und
hat Verbindungen zur qn und Szene der
rechtsextremen Partei der dritte Weg zu
den gelbwesten und zur Rechten
Bürgerwehren dem Thüringer
Verfassungsschutz ist er bereits als
Rechtsextremist bekannt 2019 soll er mit
mutmaßlichen Rechtsterroristen in einer
Asylunterkunft eingedrungen sein sobald
so problematisch doch das wirklich
Interessante an Frank dem Reisenden ist
dass er sich telegram zu Nutze gemacht
hat wie kaum ein anderer im
deutschsprachigen Raum die zweite
wichtige Person war Engel mit Feuer
sowohl Engel mit Feuer als auch Frank
der Reisende haben schon immer die
Verbindung zum rechtsextremen Millionen
zum verschwörungsideologischen Milieu
gesucht Wir wissen bei Engel mit Feuer
zum Beispiel dass sie als Reichsbürger
in bezeichnet werden kann
weil sie zum Beispiel selbst immer
wieder Behauptung aufstellt wie
Deutschland hätte keine Friedensvertrag
und ähnliches und vor kurzem taucht sie
in einem telegram-video auf und
verbreitet russische Propaganda das
Problem hat eben dann im Gefäß nachdem
die Ukraine auch noch in die NATO wollte
dass das so nicht mehr weitergeht das
denke ich mal das war auch eher ein
Vorwand weil ja doch gerade das mit
diesen babystationen und
leihmutterschaften und diesen ganzen
biolatoren direkt beim vor der Haustiere
quasi gestanden ist und da muss man
natürlich mal irgendwas unternehmen wenn
dann der ganze Abschaum da schon bei dir
im Flur steht da muss man natürlich dann
mal handeln oder hänge mit Feuer und
Frank der Reisende sind glaube ich
Personen die mit zu den aktivsten
telegram-nutzer in Deutschland zählen
mehrere hunderttausend Nachrichten
geschrieben über die letzten Jahre beide
sind auch extrem Nutzer zum Beispiel
Frank der Reisende gibt anders am mehr
als 4000 Kanäle und er bezeichnet das
Projekte betreut auf telegram
Engel mit Feuer hat auch mehrere Dutzend
Kanäle und Gruppen diese betreut na du
meldest dich zwar selbst nicht mehr auf
seinem Kanal aber er lässt Frank den
Reisenden und Engel mit Feuer weiter
ihre radikalen Inhalte posten ich glaube
die meisten wissen gar nicht dass hinter
dem Kanal der jetzt Xavier Naidoo
zugeordnet wird gar nicht mehr gesehen
na du steht die Administratorin hinter
dem Kanal gibt sich auch sehr viel Mühe
es so darzustellen das wäre es Xavier
Naidoos Kanal und das ist nicht nur ein
Name sondern eine Marke mit großer
Reichweite und vielen Fans er trägt also
definitiv Verantwortung dafür er
schreitet nicht ein wenn Engel mit Feuer
Sprachnachrichten hochlädt die
eigentlich schon eineinhalb Jahre alt
sind und die suggerieren das ob sie
aktuell wären und damit gibt es auch so
ein bisschen einfach seinen Namen her
für Desinformationen
Verschwörungsideologien und
Antisemitismus es gibt quasi eine Art
Fake von Xavier Naidoo auf telegram
noch bevor das distanzierungsvideo
auftauchte kam es hinter den Kulissen
zum Streit hollenburger zur Folge hat
Frank der Reisende Engel mit Feuer am 11
April 2022 offenbar aus naido's Kanal
entfernt Engel mit Feuer wiederum
behauptet jetzt Frank der Reisende und
die anderen Admins seien vom
Verfassungsschutz sie selbst sah nämlich
wegen Volksverhetzung verurteilt auch
wenn sich naidou nach seinem
distanzierungsvideo von der Plattform
zurückgezogen hat werden unter seinem
Namen weiterhin Nachrichten mit
hochgefährlichen Inhalten an
zehntausende Menschen geschickt Rechte
drahtzia in nutzen seinen Kanal um Hetze
Hassbotschaften und Propaganda weiter zu
streuen aber wo ist Naidoo jetzt was
treibt er und hat sein
distanzierungsvideo womöglich mit
Comeback Plänen zu tun wir haben uns
nach seinem abtauchen auf die Spur
gemacht ich habe das schon eine
spinnernde Begriffe Quatsch gehalten und
habe das unterschätzt dazu gibt es eine
ganze Folge die Spur in der ZDF
Mediathek ich freue mich sehr wenn ihr
reinschaut